Well, I must say it was the time
when we had to open up grease interceptors.
And grease interceptors are these tanks
that they are underground
that all the food waste
coming from a restaurant would go into,
and it's supposed to trap grease and food particles.
And we had to open these manholes
and extract samples from these grease interceptors.
And we had to do one
where we had to monitor it for 24 hours,
and it was really quite difficult working conditions.
But we realized it was very important to do this
because we had to understand what was happening
inside these grease interceptors,
so that we could understand the fate
of a lot of contaminants that entered the sewer systems,
and the wastewater treatment plants,
and eventually our rivers and lakes.
Click any of these fortune cookies
to see your questions and follow-up questions explored.
Click this cookie to return to the intro video
and see what this series is all about,
or click this cookie to suggest
alternative questions,
participants,
or career paths
for future videos.